as i said we will get to those local
election results in just a moment but
first let's talk about kierstama more
allegations in the newspapers this
morning
the sunday times claiming that sources
say kistama didn't do work after eating
as he claimed the mail on sunday he's
got a leaked memo which it claims shows
the event and the curry was planned
in advance this dinner in miners hall
with mary foy at the air candidate
now labour of course say no rules are
broken they're happy to answer that any
questions so can you just just tell us
exactly
exactly what happened you know was the
event planned in advance was work done
afterwards what actually went on
well i think there's no the operations
note that the mail on sunday has got
hold of um demonstrates exactly what
went on was exactly what kierstarma said
went on he went on a work visit
he um stopped to eat at various times
during the day as was
factored into the work visit
and then he finished the work visit and
he went back to his hotel
i think the this the last few weeks
we've seen an absolutely desperate
attempt to sling mud at the labour
leader and various members of the labour
party and it is frankly absurd of the
tories to claim that this in any way
equates to a prime minister who was
under investigation by the police for 12
separate gatherings which included
karaoke parties bringing your own bottle
parties um
pub quizzes
suitcases full of wine being smuggled
through the back door and
the prime minister lied about that he
denied that they happened he denied that
he was there he came clean and he
laughed about it kyocera went on a work
visit and had a break to eat the idea
that this is the same sort of thing is
just a sign of a government that is
tired is desperate and is completely out
of ideas that spends more time slinging
mud at the labour party than working out
how they're going to deal with
pensioners who are now struggling so
much to heat their homes that they're
having to get on buses in order to avoid
the cold it's about time that this
government just gave up with this
desperate attempt and went for the sake
of this country
okay well let's just put to one side any
comparisons with boris johnson or what
happened in number 10 downing street
let's just put that to one side
kirsten was being investigated by the
police about whether or not he broke the
law if they find that he broke the law
should he resign
look i'm not going to get into that
because it's i'm absolutely confident
that he hasn't broken the law he was
investigating you get into it
genuinely
but i i am struggling to understand why
nobody will engage in this legitimate
question when kirsten is literally under
investigation
by the police if you're so confident i
understand that you know if labour says
we're absolutely confident no rules were
broken if they were of course he'll
resign but you know why just be clear on
what that is i don't understand
because it lends legitimacy to something
that is completely and utterly absurd
that is a desperate attempt by the
government to deflect from the fact that
during police from the highest inflation
rate in a generation and people are
struggling to survive and i'm just i'm
not going to entertain it because i'm
absolutely confident that no rules were
broken not least because this was
investigated last time the conservatives
tried to sling mud at us and kirsten
armour was found to be completely in the
clear this is a guy who self-isolated
six times during the pandemic i don't
know a single other person who did that
he is mr rules he does not break the
rules he was the director of public
prosecutions not somebody who goes
around tearing up rules when it suits
him in stark contrast to the prime
minister i have to say i think this
desperate attempt to sling mud will fall
flat but i think we'll see more of this
as we get closer to a general election
the one thing that the conservatives
don't want to talk about is what is
actually happening to people in this
country right now and that's what we're
focused on the easiest way to shut down
these questions and to focus on the
issues you want is just to give a
straight answer about what would happen
if durham police find mr rules did break
the rules and we know of course why
we're talking about this because he has
been as you say
very strong in criticizing the
government and calling on them to resign
i just want to look at a tweet from
kirstama at the end of january
after months of denials the prime
minister is now under criminal
investigation for breaking his own
lockdown laws he needs to do the decent
thing and resign now the crucial thing
about this is the date this is before
any fines were issued
your leader is now under investigation
for breaking lockdown laws surely in his
uh if you'll have his own standards
applied to him then kirsten needs to
resign just for being under
investigation
but sophie look i've already answered
that question that that tweet that
called for boris johnson to resign was a
time when the prime minister was under
investigation for 12 separate gatherings
at downing street which he denied for
months had even happened let alone that
he was there and only came clean when he
was caught red-handed
that included karaoke parties bring your
own bottle parties leaving drinks
celebration drinks suitcases full of
wine being smuggled in through the back
door of downing street it is absurd to
equate that to a work
visit with planned breaks to eat it was
not illegal to eat and the longer that
this goes on the reason that we're
talking about it is not because labour
won't answer a straight answer the
reason we're talking about it is because
this government is desperate and they
are throwing mud at the labour party to
deflect from their own families
the longer that we talk about this and
the less that we talk about that what is
happening to people in the country the
more it fuels the sense that politicians
are out of touch and that's what boris
johnson wants and we're determined not
to allow him to do it okay you're very
clear in your answers you don't think
kirstama will be found guilty
if he does it is hard to see how he
could potentially stay on this leader
if the ball to coin afraid
to coin a phrase did come loose at the
back of the of the scrum would you fancy
have another crack at the leadership
look i stood to be leader of the labour
party
because i believe that our nations and
regions across britain had been
fundamentally underserved for decades
and we needed to turn that around we
need to get good jobs backed into towns
like wigan and across the country and we
need to start putting money in people's
pockets and rebuilding our communities
that's the job that kierstama has handed
me and for 12 years i've just watched
with absolute desperation as the tories
have visited misery
on people across this country that's why
we've got to get into government and
we've got to turn this around you saw on
thursday that we're starting to do that
that we're starting to fight our way
back in communities where people said it
just wasn't possible only three years
ago and in a couple of years time that
is our responsibility we've got to be in
government get rid of this tired
desperate government and start to turn
around the fortunes of the people in
this country
that sounded a little bit like another
leadership pitch to me
it's it's a pitch to the country that we
need a labour government led by kierst
armour in a couple of years time that is
going to be able to get money back into
people's pockets deal with the immediate
crisis and start to rebuild this country
from the ground up this country cannot
afford more of the conservatives and
there is absolutely no question in my
mind that we can't muck around with
internal debates in the labour party
about who's up and who's down we've got
a leader who even in these last few days
with huge amounts of mud being slung at
him has come out of this showing the
same honesty and character
and grit that he's shown all the way
through during the leadership contest
when we're at competitors and since and
we are absolutely determined that we're
going to stand together fight together
and win the future of this country
together
okay uh now i am keen to talk about the
local election results we spoke to
donald trump about the difficult
performance that the conservatives had
but i just want to look at labour
because
i accept that you know progress was made
in some areas uh by labour but you
actually lost vote share in every part
of the country apart from london you
also gained fewer seats than the lib
dems and the green party in england
we're looking at the graph now labour
putting on 28 seats in england that's
compared to 191 for the lib dems and the
61
for the green party and it's pretty
clear isn't it by these results that
people are unhappy with the
conservatives but they're not
necessarily just coming to labour why
not
well three years ago i came on your show
after we just lost our entire labour
base
in every nation and region of the uk
and i think you could see that it was
clear i honestly didn't know if that
break that decisive break that people
had made with us was going to be
permanent it you know these are parts of
the country where like berry like
rottendale like parts of cumbria where
once we were them and they were us and
that break was painful and i wasn't sure
if it was going to be permanent i think
thursday showed the opposite actually i
think it showed that the path back to
power for labour is steep but it doesn't
have to be long and we're making
progress in every region and nation now
in scotland in wales and in and in
england in parts of the country where
you know i watched i watched us lose
labour mps i lost watched us lose good
people and i wondered if we'd ever
repair that damage we did start to
repair that damage on thursday this was
the turning point for us and i'm
absolutely determined now that this is a
start not the end that we now get on the
front foot to convince people that we're
not just an effective opposition who've
won the right to be heard but we are a
genuine alternative to this awful tory
government that can actually start to
deliver on the things that people care
about like getting money back into
people's pockets through winfield tax
like investing in good jobs in every
community in this country we've started
to set that out but you're going to see
a lot more of that from me from care
from rachel reeves and others over the
next few months do you think labour
needs to be much more bold than in the
policy platform to deal with the cost of
living crisis that's coming down the
road
i think we've been pretty bold so far
we've struck out um
the last um labour party conference by
promising to invest 28 billion a year
every year over the next decade in good
clean jobs in communities that have seen
jobs bleeding out of those communities
for the last 40 years i think you know
we have a lot of debate in the labour
party about whether to be radical i
think the key is to be relevant people
need money in their pockets right now
that's why we're calling for a winful
tax on the big oil and gas producers we
need to get that money back into the
pockets not just because families and
businesses are struggling to survive but
because it's a nonsense to say as
michael gove is saying that you can
start to rebuild our economies and
rebuild our high streets and town
centres if people simply don't have
money to spend we we care about the same
things that people in this country care
about they're not getting a hearing at
the moment in the media or the political
debate and it's our job to make sure
that they do
okay i'm keen to talk to you about the
situation in northern ireland as well
with shin fein uh winning that historic
victory
in those assembly elections um now mary
lou macdonald the president of chimpaine
has already started talking about the
possibility of a border pole saying a
referendum could be possible within a
five-year time frame
what is the labor party's position on a
border pole in northern ireland
well look we're we believe in the united
kingdom we're not we're not neutral
about that we we
fought for and will strive for and argue
for the future of the united kingdom for
as long as we exist we respect the good
friday agreement and we would
play our role in government as an honest
broker in that but look i think these
elections in northern ireland are
historic and they are significant it's
very clear that people were voting
for change in the last um in the last
set of elections but that does not
equate to voting to
trigger a border poll the good friday
agreement is absolutely clear that there
has to be
a clear majority for that in northern
ireland before that is triggered and i
don't think that those conditions have
in any sense been met most of the major
parties including sinn fein fought these
elections on the cost of living crisis
that is engulfing people in northern
ireland just as it's engulfing people
across the united kingdom will support
to to in their aim to get the executive
up and running as quickly as possible
they hope to do that next week and then
to start focusing on the things that
they won this election on which is the
cost of living crisis and getting money
back into people's pockets and just
finally there's some real concerns about
the ability to actually form an
executive at all with the dep
saying that they're prepared to you know
collapse the paracham arrangement refuse
to join an elect an executive until the
northern ireland protocol is dealt with
now dominant rabbi earlier on the show
said that it needs to be dealt with as
soon as possible what do you think needs
to happen
and we've long been calling for a
veterinary agreement that would help to
break down some of those borders and
barriers that currently exist because of
the northern ireland protocol that boris
johnson negotiated
i think on a broader point you know
at any time in the history of northern
ireland when recent history when there's
been a problem it has usually fallen to
the british prime minister to try to use
his or her personal authority to bring
sides together and to negotiate through
this the difficulty that we find
ourselves in now is that boris johnson
is not seen as an honest broker he is
the person who helped to write the the
architecture of this problem rather than
resolve it i think the key over the next
couple of weeks for the government is
that they've got to get on and resolve
these issues around the northern ireland
protocol because at the moment i have to
say the lack of trust in the prime
minister himself is part of what is
fueling this crisis in northern ireland
so get that agreement in place yes and
the nuts and bolts of it but also boris
johnson has a lot of work to do i think
to prove to people in northern ireland
that he can be trusted